the war that ended the world started on
October 9
1971. tensions had been brewing for
years between America and the Soviet
Union and even though people had done
their best to keep a sense of normalcy
everyone was wondering when the cold war
that had been brewing for the past 30
years would boil over there were those
who had been preparing for it for years
While others assumed that it would never
amount to anything neither Nation wanted
to make the first nuclear strike and
even if that happened the engineers
would come out of their underground
cities to intervene but nobody knew for
sure of the two World superpowers could
ever come to an agreement or if it would
all end in total Destruction October 9th
was the day that question was finally
answered the first American nuclear
warhead detonated over the Gulf of
Finland only a few miles away from the
city of Leningrad where people were
going about their day blissfully unaware
of the destruction that was about to
befall them first came a city-wide
blackout as the power grid was bombarded
with a huge surge of radiation that
caused bulbs to blow and wires to glow
like they'd been struck by lightning
there was barely any time to react
before the next wave hit a white hot
flash so bright that many of those who
couldn't get to cover were blind
the third Wave by far the most
destructive was the force of the
explosion itself like a powerful burning
wind it swept through the city breaking
Windows knocking over street lights
ripping the leaves off trees and bathing
every car building and person with Ash
people are trapped under the debris as
some of the city's older less
well-maintained buildings come crumbling
down even though the Soviet government
had been preparing for this day to come
and the Russian people had been put
through mandatory safety drills no
amount of practice or planning could
have prepared them for the real thing
the streets erupted into chaos cars were
crashing into buildings either because
their drivers had been Blinded By the
Light of the distant explosion or
because the initial wave of radiation
had shorted their batteries people
nearly trampled each other trying to get
to underground shelters as police and
military tried to yell directions over
the cacophony among the crowd of family
desperately tried to stay together Arena
and Nikolai bellach off held tight to
their children Alexi and Tatiana the
whole family was still in their pajamas
and barely had time to get their shoes
on before they started rushing towards
the neighborhood's designated
underground bunker Arena had Tatiana who
was only two clutch type to her chest
and Nikolai tried his best to keep 10
year old Alexi's eyes shielded as they
walked past the dead bodies of people
who were once their friends and
neighbors it will be all right soon son
Nikolai said as much as to try and
convince himself as his son but a going
on the ground just like in the safety
Thrills Alexi nodded solemnly and kept
his gaze Straight Ahead they were almost
at the end of the street when just above
the sounds of air raid sirens and
screaming people Alexi heard a familiar
voice
the boy looked down to see his teacher
Mr Petrov trapped in the wreckage of his
car he must have been driving to work
when the bomb struck father stop Alexa
yelled tugging at his father's shirt
sleeve that's my teacher we have to help
everybody make it to the shelter the
soldiers will help him once everyone
else is in said Nikolai Alexi didn't
listen he wriggled free of his father's
grip and ran to where his teacher lay
pinned under the wrecked vehicle Nikolai
was calling after him and though Arena
wanted to wait for Alexi to come back
she was swept up in the tide of people
and separated from her husband Mr Petrov
was crying thanking Alexi for coming to
his Aid as Alexi got closer he saw there
was blood pooling out from under the
wreck it seemed if Mr Petrov were going
to make it out his legs would likely be
badly damaged Alexi tried to lift the
car himself but even though he was
strong for his age he was still only a
child a soldier had been helping people
into the bomb shelter stopped what he
was doing and ran over to Alexi hey
the soldiers shouted leave him alone and
go back to your
to hurt yourself Alexi kicked and
struggled Against The Soldier's grip as
he was dragged back into the line with
his family but he he's in trouble Alexi
cried it's not your job to save him his
father scolded as he took his hand and
led him down the stairs where they would
rejoin his mother and sister as Alexi
and his father descended into the
tunnels Alexi heard a gunshot from the
street above though he would survive
long after that day he never saw his
teacher Mr Petrov again he never asked
his father about what happened the
velotrop family was reunited in the
underground shelter which had once been
an underground train station Tatiana had
started crying and Nikolai tried
desperately to quiet her Arena hugged
her son so tight he felt she might
squeeze the life out of him they were
packed in with a dozen other families
some they knew and others who were
strangers Alexi recognized some of the
other children from school and saw that
some were there without their parents
while they were in the station a soldier
addressed the group and explained what
would happen next the train station was
to serve as their temporary shelter
until the proper negotiations were made
with the engineers as per a treaty that
had been written and signed after the
second world war the engineers had
agreed to open the borders of their
underground civilization to humans
fleeing from a crisis above ground once
the government had made a decision the
survivors were to be taken deep
underground where they would live until
the war was over above ground the Soviet
Union began dealing with the Fallout of
the initial attack it was clear that
America could no longer be dealt with
reasonably if they were willing to bomb
one of the ussr's biggest cities though
the bombing had cut Communications
between Leningrad and Moscow eventually
contact was re-established and the Army
was able to radio the Kremlin with a
full report on the damage Leningrad was
in ruin with over a third of the
population dead or otherwise too wounded
to move underground those who had made
it underground were receiving treatment
from everything from broken bones and
blindness to radiation poisoning in a
word it was chaos Russian in Parliament
was quick and ruthless and their
decision to strike back on October 12th
secretary Brezhnev authorized nuclear
missiles to be launched at both New York
City and Washington DC Millions were
killed and just like in Russia the
survivors retreated to underground
America didn't go down without a fight
though and launched another missile
attack this time at Moscow it wasn't
long before both countries allies were
involved in the conflict as well with
missile strikes coming from France China
North Korea Germany and the United
Kingdom within a month the surface of
the Earth was dangerously irradiated and
any humans who were still living had
retreated underground but though the
world had ended the war had not Alexi
belatroff and his family struggled to
adjust to their new life underground
though the engineers were intelligent
and human-like their world was so
different from the world Alexi had lived
in for the first 10 years of his life he
barely ever saw them the engine
Engineers were nocturnal sleeping while
an artificial sun nourished the
genetically engineered plants that grew
around the city but any time he tried to
ask questions about them he was met with
hushed Silence by the adults the
engineers were spoken of in hushed
almost reverent tones they were the
beings that saved Humanity yes but they
had also helped build the weapons that
led to the war in the first place Alexi
barely had any time to settle into this
new life before what remained the
Russian army started looking for new
recruits reports had come in from an
above ground Scout that the Americans
were working on a new type of armor that
could fully Shield the wearer against
radiation and the Soviets could not
afford to be outmatched when their army
was still recovering from multiple
nuclear attacks but the Army wasn't
asking for able-bodied adult men to
enlist they were looking for children we
can't possibly send our son to war Arena
said arguments at the dinner table had
become common in the bellatrov family he
would not be going to war Nikolai argued
not until their new anti-radiation
technology is perfected he won't be
ready until he's an adult how do you
know that what they're making in those
labs won't kill him Arena said do we
really want to trust these underground
Devils with our son how much do we
really know about the engineers anyway
they could have let us all burn on this
surface Nikolai said but they didn't I
think we should trust them I want to go
said Alexa I should some of my friends
have already enlisted both of his
parents were stunned but it made sense
to Alexi he wanted the war to be over
and he wanted to leave the underground
city but most importantly he wanted to
know if anyone was still alive on the
surface if there was even a sliver of
chance that it could be habitable again
he wanted to find out after much
discussion Arena and Nikolai agreed it
was what was best for the future of
Russia and ultimately the future of the
human race Alexi's parents delivered him
to the office of Army Recruitment and he
was taken by a man named Commander
volkov to a specialized research
facility this was when Alexi met an
engineer for the first time the engineer
was tall and hairy like a bear walking
on its back legs but with face and hands
more like a human's it was overseeing a
group of humans and other Engineers as
they tinkered with machines that Alexi
couldn't even begin to guess the purpose
of do not be frightened the Lexi
Commander volkov said they're going to
explain the procedure to you before you
have to agree to anything the engineer
looked the boy over then held up ajar
containing something that looked like an
insect's exoskeleton it was green the
same shade as the ussr's army uniforms
this is a new bio-organic armor
prototype the engineer said we can only
graph it onto you while you are still
growing it must grow with you starting
on your back then moving to your limbs
then your head Alexi was frightened by
the idea but didn't want to seem weak he
wanted to make sure his father would be
proud of him he was taken into surgery
with a team of Engineers and human
doctors grafted the plate of bio-organic
armor onto his spine once the surgery
was over he was wheeled into a recovery
room where he was fed a simple meal
alongside all of his friends and
classmates they had all gone through the
same procedure over the next eight years
Alexey and his comrades went through the
painful process of growing their
exoskeleton like the engineer had said
it grew with them but the growth
happened in painful spurts rather than
gradually the worst thing about the
armor was that it couldn't be removed
but it gave them many advantages to
normal soldiers as well once it covered
Alexi's legs he found he could jump
higher and run farther than any human
normally could when it grew over his
arms it gave him increased strength by
the time he was 18 it had covered his
head giving it a fly-like appearance but
also granting him stereoscopic vision
and the ability to hear radio
Transmissions without the need for any
other communication device during this
time he and the other boys were trained
by Commander volkov learning how to use
the powers granted to them by their
exoskeletons for combat when they were
deemed ready they were all outfitted
with shoulder cannons Supply packs and
guns all of which were also bioorganic
and were surgically attached it had been
eight long years since the end of the
world and Alexi was now able to set foot
back on the surface the world he
returned to was almost unrecognizable
there were no signs of life outside of
weeds and Vines overtaking the
irradiated ruins of buildings within the
first hour of returning to the surface
Alexi gave up any hope of finding
survivors he heard volkov's boys barking
orders through the suit there was no
time to reminisce about the past the
soldiers had a job to do want an anomaly
of your own check out scpswag.com for
high quality SCP merch now go check out
scp-2273 major Alexi bellatrov and what
actually happened to Major Alexi
bellatrov
scp-2273 tail for more from the story of
this interdimensional Soldier